The TV drama focuses on the work of fictional anti-graft investigators...
...whose job is to take down corrupt government officials,...
...whether powerful bureaucrats or low-ranking officers.
The viewers who saw the first episode...
...say the series doesn't appear to be entirely fictional,...
...noting similarities between the character of one corrupt official...
...and Wei Pengyuan, a former senior energy official...
...who was found to have more than 200 million yuan...
...or 29 million US dollars in cash at home.
Wei was found guilty of taking bribes and he had been given a suspended death penalty in October.
One might think that a politically-themed series would only attract older fans.
However, the fan base of the "In The Name of the People" has a wide age span...
...from teenagers to seniors.